hands up if you still miss riley and
maya we do too
although girl meets world ended in 2017
we still
love to discover the behind the scenes
secrets from the disney channel show
we've got the lowdown on how the
characters could have been totally
different
thanks to casting revelations from the
actors themselves you'll love learning
about little-known family connections
stained hair shockers and kisses that
were never shown
why did you do that i don't know i just
wanted you to stop
we can't imagine the matthews family
being any different but did you know
that riley
was supposed to have an older brother
named elliot actor teo holm was cast for
the part but that actor was eventually
dropped from the show
in october 2013 teo tweeted the sad news
saying
so guys disney decided that it wouldn't
work to have an older brother on the
show
i won't be on girl meets world thank you
to everyone his would be tv mom danielle
fishel who plays topanga replied on
twitter
tayo you are an incredible talent and i
adore you you may still call me mom uh
what a sweetheart we wish danielle was
our tv mom
you have a job and you still make time
to take care of me and auggie
so why did the studio cut the character
a disney channel rep explained to tv
line that
tail's departure from the show was
simply one of those things saying
various creative changes are often made
as a project transitions from pilot to
series
we would be so disappointed to get so
close and yet end up so far from a big
opportunity like that
do you think that taiyo watched the show
or would it have been too difficult
i was really sad like i don't know why i
got so sad if it's tricky to imagine the
matthews family having another child
then what about imagining sabrina
carpenter being in that family instead
of rowan blanchard
it sounds hard to believe but girl meets
world could have been very different
we're so used to seeing sabrina as maya
hart and rowan as riley matthews that we
can't picture it any other way
but in an interview with premiere in
2015 rowan revealed that they started
out the opposite way around
she said sabrina originally auditioned
for riley and i originally auditioned
for maya and then we swapped about two
auditions in
could you picture them playing each
other's characters we really can't
it was a super long process it started
in november 2012 and she went through
eight auditions
rowan even admitted that she cried in
the first audition that's because there
was some uncertainty about how old the
character should be
but it all worked out fine in the end
for rowan and we are relieved
michael brought me back and here we are
that is so cool
do you remember the paint fight in
season three's girl meets up state
episode
well when riley threw purple paint over
maya it had quite the effect on
sabrina's hair
celebrity hairstylist for the show lori
heaps dished that the purple paint
actually stained sabrina's
hair that's got to be up there with one
of the worst hair nightmares
laurie shared a picture on instagram in
march 2016
of sabrina's honey blonde locks with a
caption revealing that
sabrina's hair was accidentally stained
purple from paint used in a scene the
day before
real inspiration has no hours
fortunately her pro skills meant that
she could fix it with a new dye job
phew hair crisis averted did you know
that the color choice of purple paint
might well have been linked to the
disney channel original movie
descendants
fans wondered if the purple hair was a
shout out to maul from the dcom
of course maul's purple do is her
signature look but we're not sure if
maya's purple hair was really a
reference to that what do you think
you're ally and i'm maya just like it's
always been
we love uncovering little-known facts
from our favorite childhood tv shows
and discovering a family link to sabrina
carpenter is right up there with our
favorite facts
did you know sabrina's sister sarah
appeared on girl meets world you might
not have realized because sarah played a
background character rather than a lead
role but she appeared in several
episodes as a student with brown hair
and glasses
keep your eyes peeled the next time you
watch a re-run of the show and see if
you can spot her
yeah you and the rest of the city sarah
carpenter is two and a half years older
than sabrina
sarah was born in october 1996 and
sabrina was born in may
1999 and sarah's very proud of her
famous little sister
she shared an adorable throwback pic on
instagram of herself and sabrina as
little kids to celebrate sabrina's 21st
birthday on may 11th
2020 sarah also shares photos of the two
of them in the present day
they sure look like sisterly best
friends i had an amazing time spending
my vacation with my sister
the moment when maya and lucas almost
kisses epic
we know you'd never forget the details
but let's go back over what happened in
the girl meets texas part 2 episode of
season 2 because what you might not know
is that it could have worked out very
differently the two of them are alone by
the campfire when lucas
asks maya you like me when she starts
making fun of him he pulls her close and
leans in as if he's about to kiss her
of course they don't go through with the
kiss in the scene that aired but did you
know that there's an alternate version
that they filmed
a fan found a photo of the actors
sharing an actual kiss
and tweeted it to the show's writers
account the fan asked was there really a
campfire kiss in the photo and the
writer's account replied
we shot the scene two ways we felt the
other scene was better for where the
story was going
do you wish the writers had gone with
the actual kiss scene or are you happy
that they stuck with the version that
made it onto our screens
i don't want to have any more secrets
from her sabrina
and sarah carpenter aren't the only
family connection on girl meets world
the show's creator michael jacobs
brought three of his children
onto the writing team his sons aaron
david and joshua jacobs all wrote some
of the episodes
and that's not the only family link it's
also thought that the character joshua
matthews was named after michael's
son of course that character originally
made an appearance on boy meets world
but he appeared more regularly on girl
meets world
niece well kept it so long welcome to
the party guys enjoy
and the character rachel mcguire from
boy meets world is thought to be named
after michael's daughter
rachel in fact four of michael's kids
appeared on boy meets world when they
were little
joshua jacobs's appearance in the
episode eric hollywood was like a
prediction of the future
as he played a tv writer for kids get
acquainted with the universe it just
goes to show that hollywood dreams can
come true
especially when your dad is a big deal
in the tv industry
the world you're gonna be part of it
someday
if you had to guess which cast member
from girl meets world played the most
tricks on the other actors
who would you choose we'd have ben
savage down as the class clown or should
we say
onset clown but the actor who plays cory
matthews was actually the one getting
tricks played on him
it's rowan who was the big fan of
playing practical jokes
she told youth village that she's the
biggest trickster on set
rowan said that although we'd never
guess it she's played loads of jokes
that'll always get people laughing
we asked them to take out the middle so
her favorite was when you tp someone's
room tp stands for toilet paper and so
you cover their room in clean toilet
paper
she finds that joke particularly
hilarious she did it to ben savage's
dressing room on more than one occasion
ben himself dished that rowan has a
helper too he revealed that both rowan
and sabrina always play tricks on him
like on valentine's day when they
completely covered his dressing room in
little pictures with random quotes on
them
luckily he thought it was hilarious too
which joke do you think is funnier
though
the toilet paper trick or the quotes
trick things will start happening to you
that you don't understand it'll confuse
you
but it's a magical time it's always
interesting to learn about the
similarities actors find between
themselves and the characters they play
and payton meyer found a connection with
his character lucas
in an interview with fan lala he spoke
about what he really loved about lucas's
development in season two he explained
how lucas had moved from his old town
and learned how to really fit in
into his new town new york peyton
continued i moved from actually
las vegas to los angeles it took me a
while to fit in and then finally you
fit into that piece peyton really loved
how lucas started to fit into his new
place in season two as well
which of the girl meets world characters
do you most identify with having shared
experiences
sure helps create a sense of connection
we've decided we're gonna take a
breath first and find out who we all are
it must be fun for danielle fishel who
plays topanga to notice similarities
between herself as a child actor on boy
meets world and the actors who played
the younger generation in girl meets
world
and she revealed how rowan and sabrina
loved to sneak into the writer's room
just like she did during boy meets world
she spoke out about it in a
behind-the-scenes tour with michael
jacobs who created both shows
michael asked danielle if she remembered
in the original show how she used to
visit the writer's room and would want
to know what was going on
he pointed out that the same thing was
happening with rowan and sabrina on the
new show danielle replied
i know they do it every single day
they're always like all right guys quick
grab our lunch we want to come up here
i'm like really probably busy speaking
of the writers we've already heard how
michael's kids were on the team but
there were other writers who were
originally on the staff of boy meets
world 2.
that's mark blutman jeff mennell and
matthew nelson and it sounds like the
writing team enjoyed collaborating with
the actors
in her interview with premiere rowan
revealed that we all kind of just pitch
in our writers are incredible
we almost had a very different riley as
rowan wasn't keen on working with disney
to begin with
she dropped that revelation in an
interview with edit magazine in 2017
after the show had wrapped rowan
revealed that when her agent sent over
girl meets world
she said i will not do disney ever in my
life oh
rowan don't hold back but why wasn't
rowan keen
she said that although she watched
disney she always thought that if you
wanted to be a serious film actress then
you couldn't be a disney actress
do you agree with her rowan still thinks
that it's partially true
because after appearing on the disney
channel show she did have to work harder
to be taken seriously so why did she
decide to join the disney family it was
down to the material and the format of
the show
she loved how each episode was lesson
based and teaching the audience
something worthwhile
am i ever going to take a risk that
changes my destiny it tied in with when
she started discovering activism she
spoke with the writers if she didn't
like something
and they made her feel heard and
respected in a way that she hadn't on
previous sets
she also spoke about her activism in
real life saying if i can post about a
protest and get more people
to go out protesting and that's i feel
like i've achieved something we can't
imagine the show without rowan as
riley which girl meets world behind the
scenes secret surprised you the most
be sure to tell us in the comments below
and hit that subscribe button to be the
first to know when we upload more videos
on the things
thanks for watching